hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Red Dead Redemption
okay I got a path that I can go for here
I got to go for this guy that LeMans
Strauss wants me to hunt down now for a
number of reasons to gunfire well it
seems like something I should probably
intervene on okay hang on let's get my
rifle out I don't know why you guys
decided that I needed to be shot at punk
okay well you guys probably shouldn't
stand there where I can very obviously
hit you run the arm okay well you're
walking it everybody I'm glad I can just
walk up here and kill these people for
you hey howdy how are you doing there
I'm a murderer no problem yeah well I am
a hero
a goddamn Savior this land now don't
look at me that closely while I loot
these people it's uh it's all in a day's
work now don't think nothin of it it's
just I lost my contact somewhere
hmm all right well you have fun building
that house wonder if that's dynamics
there's no way there would know there
would be no way that they would have a
dynamic house building system where
settlers could just build houses
wherever that would be amazing if they
did but I highly highly doubt that
that's actually the situation here cuz I
would be way way way too ridiculous but
then again this game is surprising me
before so maybe honestly who knows howdy
hello hello how are you
honestly like I bet if I had more time
because I know that the main game is
probably like I suppose a beer don't
tell me where I isn't ain't supposed to
be what why what what what's your
problem man whoa whoa whoa easy easy
easy
Oh what the [ __ ] what's wrong with
you I just popped by to say hi what's
your deal dude what is the deal you were
having a nice day you were having a nice
life and then you just decided to shoot
me I wasn't doing [ __ ] to you you drew
your gun I was trying to man that said
all right whatever I'll take your [ __ ]
though I don't feel bad about that you
shoot me damn it what's your family
gonna do all right fine platinum engrave
buckle like a weighted negative but he
shot me that wasn't me that weren't me
that weren't me none at all also I know
that some of you were playing the game
where you take a shot every time I do
like a quote-unquote cowboy accident
accent but uh yeah well I'm sorry you're
all dead from alcohol poisoning by now
hey mr. downs waiting everyone's so
scared of me mr. Thomas downs
well yes charity mr. downs
mr. mr. downs he's scared stiff you
don't know what to do uh-huh so why did
you borrow in the first place you were
asking the whole town for money what did
you need money for I mean not that I
assumed you took any of you say huh
[Music]
why'd you make me hit you why why are
you making me hate you sorry this porn
is blogging on you uh-huh okay all right
I got you
our guy you buy your luscious lips
please here's my compassion okay never
mind you owe him you took the money he
wants it back what's not to understand
where's our money I don't have it
sell your place we already owe more than
it's worth then sell your wife are your
family is something we ain't your idea
charity Jaclyn Thomas what are you
looking at Thomas I said what you
looking at woman husband isn't well if
we could just have more like I said we
ain't nobody's out there journey get us
the money
oh man I feel bad I mean I know I'm an
outlaw I'm a gunslinger I've killed more
people than I can count
I know but boy I still feel bad oh
that's beautiful yeah that really
soothes my bad feelings say heat waves
in the background oh that's cool
god damn it's cool well I don't know why
this is altering cinematic but I had a
feeling that this particular mission was
gonna be particularly story movie for
some reason I mean it was the only one
left and I have a funny feeling that
that's the idea mine no wait he's gonna
get me sick wait he coughed in my face
with his blood that's not good hey um
what that's not good that's what you
might call not good that's what you
might call not good hey err Strauss we
got a problem
number one the sick guy got coughing my
face with his blood done did shoot up my
nostrils is that bad air Strauss do you
think maybe you could probably do
something about that fix me up a remedy
or some hello lady ha ha
excuse me I got a call from something
severe air Strauss air Strauss there you
are enjoying the view well heck I would
too it's a beautiful view
man I'm so good he's almost dead and
they see more or less destitute you were
fool Philander than the money mad people
who aren't desperate don't seem so
interested in my propositions of course
okay well that's all then well what are
we out of here oh that was it I thought
it was gonna be particularly story
moving hey Dutch all right you guys are
having a special moment here wouldn't
want to introduce in crude intrude boss
you invited me though I might intrude
but I'm not gonna intrude without being
invited you know how it is you know who
wants to talk to me I say I'm gonna see
about upgrading the camp because I'm
if there's something to be done if I
upgrade Duchess tent which is something
that he wants maybe that's gonna advance
it a little more if the whole thing goes
a little farther okay
220 do we have 220 we might oh we do ah
give to the poor yeah yeah Dutch yeah
the poor yeah okay give to the poor all
right yeah sure whatever you say buddy
okay well that didn't look that upgraded
Arthur wants a map to help plan journeys
oh well that seems nice but I don't have
any money for that because I can't get
one goddamn I guess I did get one done
correctly but that's besides the point
okay where are we going next
oh it's actually right here John John
Marston Johnny boy John John John John
you son of a tit
No shut up Lenny john marston hey Arthur
john marston yeah you do and you sack of
[ __ ] are you all local told me something
about a train Mary Beth overheard
something about a train full of wealthy
folk rolling down through scarlet
meadows just south of state border yes
need help with it I ain't even sure
about doing it come on at night not too
guarded it's perfect all right throw it
through stopping a train pain in the air
sure but what if we could force a train
to stop of course we get a wagon full of
some flammable oil put it on the tracks
they see it they know they either have
to stop or die you know train driver
wants to be cooked alive
kind of brilliant mm-hmm for you and
that is real idea I think that's the
first time you ever had one of them shut
up you might be the first bastard to
ever have half his brains eaten by a
wolf and end up more intelligent so
we're doing it yeah we're gonna need
ammunition guns look real frightening
and some dynamite to open up the Train
I'll get the supplies got a head into
town for Abigail anyway
don't even ask you go find us an oil
wagon yeah I know just the place they're
always heading into that refinery
there's an old run-down Shack just over
the border north of a place called
Dewberry Creek leave it hidden somewhere
near there Oh John I miss you John I
miss you I miss looking at your butt
waggle when I move my character around
I've got Arthur's stocky build going on
here it's not the same wagons that can
be stolen for John or blipped with
little Lilith all right okay blipped
with blaa blaa blaa you say there's an
eg Emmett Granger should be around here
oh that's right for the thing and what's
this Micah Bell well I don't want to
talk to Micah too much cuz mike is kind
of a son of a [ __ ] there's one in
Valentine probably not the best idea to
do that straight out of Valentine but
I've never been full the best ideas so
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna kill a deer
on the way in and then I'm gonna steal
that wagon all right let's do this
hey horsey horsey Pooh horsie horsie
horsie horsie who are you that guy from
the bar that I tried to be my friend
okay just drinking our supply then
that's okay horsey shwoop will come here
come here Scooby
Thanks whoopee okay let's go get us a
nice deer or an elk or something big
that I can kill with a rope and a knife
that's what I'm looking for all right
keep your eyes peeled everybody because
we definitely got to get this we don't
get money we're never gonna upgrade the
camp it if we don't upgrade the camp I
got a feeling we're never gonna get more
missions
he said something yeah come on come on
there we go
I marry you I'm sorry I'm sorry does me
saying sorry make it any better I don't
think so never a pleasant experience but
such is the way the wist
all right oh it's a low-quality dr2 now
you weren't even worth murdering holy
[ __ ] this rain okay I know this isn't
the most exciting thing in the world
just rain I mean I get this excited
about rain in real life so you gotta
forgive me for getting a little excited
about it here oh my god oh my god oh
it's beautiful
oh it's beautiful it's so pretty so
pretty I could live here I'd hate it cuz
I probably just got tuberculosis from
that guy coughing in my face but I could
live here
I could live here live here
I'd be so cool okay so I got a turn in
this dear and then I guess steel I
wonder if I could just turn it in hold I
mean the butcher would like that right I
always want to make the butcher happy oh
there's the oil wagon oh okay
no one's gonna notice if I steal that
I'll put on my mask that's what I'll do
I'll put on my mask and then nobody will
know what nuttin what nothing
sorry
[Music]
can I please thank you I was trying to
get on five [ __ ] forever what are you
doing over there
uh oh you guys about to you guys about
to do something god damn a horse why you
get a poop okay
I'm waiting okay that guy didn't even
try okay but you're hey can I sell this
for you
you want my dear there poor deer carcass
no displaying minor damage okay maybe I
ran over it with my horse
but it got back up okay I've got many of
broken bones
whatever fine 280 280 that's it 280
whatever okay so I'm gonna be real
sneaky about this I don't know a sneaky
I can possibly be in broad daylight but
I'm gonna try to be sneak about this in
the bush nobody knows me when I'm in the
bush watch me put on my disguise I've
got a deluxe max on the horse but hide
your identity while committing crimes
nobody knows me especially when I'm
sneaking in my bush didn't in an inning
Dannan in it no I'm in a bush you don't
know where I am aware I've come from do
you know you don't I'm in a bush done it
didn't
I'm behind hey Belle you can't possibly
know where I am or who I is
who done a man in even if you didn't and
he doesn't suspect a thing
oh guy their donor nananananana slam
bonk hey buddy how you doing
you mind if I turn it in and then and
then you're gonna go around doing
nothing in a minute don't know on the
sack I'm a sneaky here's a bush hey hey
buddy that's right you walk away walking
back to the bush you never saw me
nope uh wait wait wait I'm in here my
wagon punch there we go yep yep
don't shoot the what the oil what are
you crazy
it's alright pick up and raid easy be
thinning in it go for the bushes go for
the bushes bars all right where am I
headed I have no idea what I'm doing
whoo that's before all right there we go
I guess oh geez
I'm in a slow-ass train oh why did I
bail out are you kidding me why did I
bail i angle just like I tried to die
for a bush this is my hiding instincts
really got to me thought I saw a bush
couldn't possibly be stopped once I've
got Bush fever hey nobody could have
sway me does it sound too good but
whatever I'll stand by it
all right horsies less and less and
horsies I'm gonna say let's just be
clear horsies I'm going to slap you
until we get there oh hello dear
well if I had my other horses be fine
look out well if I have my other horse
would be fine god damn look at this
countryside it's beautiful you know I
was in Korea we saw a lot of leg
landscape and architecture and and also
just nature out there but cuz it's a
small country it's about the size of
Ohio but the the densest areas of
population are in the cities and in any
other place like there's really not that
much development out there there's a lot
of landscape and there's a lot of just
area because they really emphasize
around Seoul and Busan in the cities and
even like the city where my grandparents
are in Foshan that's it's kind of like
what they might consider to be the
boonies even if it's like not that
terribly out of the way but you know
there was a lot of beautiful beautiful
beautiful landscape it's a very
mountainous country like a lot of
mountains I mean it's guys coastal
cities and whatnot but we were driving
through with my my uncle my uncle was
driving us to me who's he's a maniac
he's the kind of guy that doesn't
believe in speed bumps and there I could
go into detail about the whole way
traffic works in in South Korea but
let's just say he he took advantage of
the speed when he could and it wasn't a
very convenient moment for any of us
because they're very painful like going
over every single speed bump at 40 miles
an hour
but that's besides the point so he was
driving us down to Busan which is a
strange story in and of itself like we
were driving down to boon Sun we left
one day and we made a whole bunch of
stops along the way to see like
landscape these mountains called the
donkey ears we went and saw this temple
that was built up in the mountains where
there was gold in the hills at one point
and then we got into Busan at like 10
o'clock at night what was that
kill some we got into Busan at 10
o'clock at night just long enough to
like go to a restaurant that we didn't
want to go to and that's another story
entirely but uh I'll tell those stories
in a bit is Jose how much time I got
here make sure I get this story right no
all right I'll tell those story in a bit
but just like there's a lot a lot a lot
of beautiful landscape out there in
Korea that uh that I never would have
imagined there to be because I went over
there like before I was a shitty kid you
know going on trip you never appreciated
the trips like when you're actually in
it as a kid but then later on you know
now that I'm older I can I can go there
and I can just be like oh [ __ ] I was so
fortunate to be able to go there at the
time and also like I'm super fortunate
to have all this family that I can
connect with that never let like never
gave up on me even though I was just
like bear whatever you know family in
Korea who cares like I'm not gonna talk
to them but in all honesty it's a
beautiful country lots and lots of
things to see okay so what am I doing
here john marston oh here we go
john marston oh [ __ ] we're leaking it's
fine
is it fine I don't think it's fine I
don't think this I don't think this is
fine that's not fine it's gonna be out
of oil but that's that's not fine all
right whatever
forget about that okay whatever we gotta
meet john marston somewhere do we got to
go back to the camp no we got to go no
that's the camp okay
oops I don't know where my horse would
be oh no my horse is way way way gone oh
well whatever so I am oh no oh no am i
hoping it oh no um can I get a ride from
somebody what hello can I help you yeah
okay hi yes oh you gonna die what's
what's your deal let's suck out the best
hey I got I'm sucking hey don't worry
I'm getting to suck hey you asked for
the best sucker in the West I'm a sucker
here we go
[Music]
look I'm the tenderest sucking man the
West funnier knowing that sucking the
venom out isn't actually a thing it
doesn't work can I bless you a rabbit I
don't think I could last you a rabbit
can i no I can't
well that's fine then all right I'm
gonna need to do something slightly
unsavory and probably steal a horse I
don't want to do it but I'm gonna have
to do it so the next horse I see coming
along this road unfortunately I'm gonna
be stealing weight you'll never see me
in my bush my ambush yeah I get it is
that were than yeah wait you sir hey sir
neck broken well you don't know that
hang out I gotta go get this horse well
your horse your horse mysteriously ran
away Oh God Jesus Christ horse but I am
such a stumpy run run so stumpy horsey
horsey horsey horse horse horse a horse
get back here horse goddamn it wasn't
this mission should have just put me
back god damn it horse where'd you go
horse horse
Oh God horse where are you oh I see it
it's in this oh my god horse horse I
shoulda last sued the horse god damn it
that's over there somewhere oh I'm tired
I'm tuckered I'm real oh there it is
okay horse horse don't get spooked by
these deer horse
please don't get spooked by the deer
deer don't get spooked by the horse the
hello dear man you guys really are mega
newbie Oh God horse good Lord horse
horse horse what the hell you're going
the complete opposite direction that I
need a horse horse you freaking [ __ ]
horse you get your horse ass back here
oh my god I did not want to train my
running skill today horse I really need
to get back to camp you're wasting a
whole bunch of time for me
I gotta go horse horse where did you go
horse
horse horse are you horsing me horse
well [ __ ] dicks and ass okay well I
guess I'm just gonna have to deal with
this another way you mr. mr. ignore the
fact that I have a mask on and alas ooh
I thought that mine not that sorry bout
it out at that bar barbar dooba daddy
thank you
well that was uh that was your fault you
know I I don't want a victim blame here
but I'm gonna absolutely victim blame
you you you you you should have known
better than to casually be walking
around with a guy with a mask in the
last Sue was coming at ya hot and heavy
so wow that was your fault oh my God
look at this Vista that is a thing of
beauty
okay anyway let me tell you a story
about how I got the boots on with my
parents in Korea so we we were obviously
going to Busan to see the city but so we
get in there about 10 o'clock at night
10 o'clock at night we roll up and by
the time we get there we're hungry by
the time we get there up and my mom to
explain how my minute mom interactions
people you know how okay imagine you
were in a situation where somebody walks
into a restaurant trying to sell
something you know how everyone would
just kind of like casually ignore I'm
just being like oh god why is this guy
here like this is the wrong place for
this my mom's the type that goes oh
you're shellings have telling me more
like come come here let me see what you
got going and then actually buys what
they're selling like negotiates haggles
and buys it so when we get out of there
like we're at like this coastal city
where there's a lot of tourist
restaurants along the coast that are
like they got people outside they're
like I made our food
dude mango pie eat our food come on and
you know you know ordinarily just look
at their you look around and find
something you actually like but my mom
the first person that yells at her to
eat at their restaurant she crosses the
street we're not even parked in a
parking space we're parked in the middle
of an intersection for some reason walks
across the street through traffic
there's traffic there's no light there's
no crosswalk [ __ ] just walks like oh
okay walks across the street and then
goes over to talk to this person like oh
okay well we don't really want to eat
here but we don't see here everybody
come out we're eating here and so the
food is like ridiculously expensive the
food is not good and I asked my mom
afterwards why the hell do we stop here
oh no that's goddamn beautiful and she
goes like well I didn't want to be rude
I'm like it's not rude if you refuse to
eat at a restaurant that you didn't want
to eat at they're yelling at you you
don't have to listen to him cause she's
like okay okay whatever you know but
it's fine so we ended up going to a
different restaurant I think like that
restaurant just to put in perspective
like food at restaurants in Korea it's
slightly cheaper than food at
restaurants like here and you get a lot
more food for it because Koreans are all
about food all about eating ooh
it is just food heaven over there and so
we eat at this restaurant and it's like
this really really mediocre fish really
mediocre for being a coastal city it was
like not good they also cheap I'm not
much for shellfish I like normal fish
just fine but shellfish and stuff I
can't do but they had this shellfish
that they cooked in cheese like they
they had an aluminum foil tin they had a
bunch of cheese in wait what what what
what what what what what no no no no no
hang on okay I'm not gonna let you get
me this time okay who's doing why here
how do I get
ie Oh
oh god well this sucks oh well there I
go headshot man I don't know how to beat
those I didn't even have my guns or
anything I better not have lost woofle
by trying to do that
I better not of Law School because those
are those are hard to counter those are
ridiculously hard to counter like I
don't know what I didn't have my rifle
they knocked me out my horse like it
said what are you supposed to do you got
no defense for it I guess Deadeye would
be a good idea now whatever all right
let me get back and I'll talk to you
again
ah oh there you are oh hell yeah
actually you know screw help the blind
hello
are you blind help a blind man okay
there you go
[Music]
you keep hidden all that matters maybe
even from yourself okay all right well
thanks for the weird fortune very
ominous okay I wasn't following you I
was actually getting on my horse so I
can do some sweet drifting okay anyway
so we eat at this restaurant it's really
really bad so imagine clams and cheese
and I'm sure clams and cheese is
actually a thing but when I had it man
that it was not good and I don't even
like clams so we spend about $100 on
barely enough food to feed the six of us
and then what ends up happening is we
leave that restaurant we go to the hotel
that's too small for any of us it was my
uncle trying to show off because he had
this like condo in Busan but it was like
a one-bedroom and there were six of us
and we were all trying to sleep there
and it wasn't working too well
but it was fine cuz like my uncle was
very nice and that was great but we
dropped our stuff off at the hotel and
then we end up going to another
restaurant a real hole-in-the-wall
restaurant like a lot of Korean
restaurants are and they were just
closing up because it's like it's almost
midnight and we walk in there and my a
my uncle my mom are like you open you
open can we eat here and they're just
like come on and it's these two old
ladies and like of course of course
we're open come on Aunt Peg Oh bah wolf
sit down in the lake oh hell yeah
and so it's like this dumpling place
really really good dumplings like
ridiculously here's a tree okay
ridiculously good dumplings great food
great eats like the whole all of us a
more food than we could ever hope to
finish all for like 25 bucks so so good
less than that cuz that was twenty five
thousand won which is less than 25 bucks
so so good loved every minute of it and
even like my uncle's friend went out
bought two whole roasts fried chickens
and just like plopped on the tail like
and the rest I'd be like okay
all right what oh hey oh hello okay and
don't you worry miss Grimshaw y'all
Crone or keep them girls in line okay
all right well they're having a party
but I gotta talk to John Marston John
John we got to do this are we doing this
what we're doing this wait what we're
da-da-da-da-da-da-da down
John John Oh camp party okay I guess we
are having a party okay all right I
guess we're partying it up I didn't know
that but sure did I McGuire that's B
okay well how do we party this okay
[Music]
the gang are celebrating the safe return
of Shana will be unavailable for other
activities for a while oh okay well fine
then yeah whatever I'm just gonna take a
nap it's the best I can hope for maybe
there'll be a party once I take a nap
I know whatever party time all right
we're gonna do morning okay man if you
if you want like to eat well like curry
has a lot of different foods like if
you're if you're into like American
foods you're probably like could it be
thrown off but it's all good because oh
it's like a lot of vegetables based on a
lot of vegetables cuz you know in Korean
culture you don't get a lot of meat no
they didn't have a lot of meat anyway so
a lot of its based on vegetables
preserved foods and stuff but now that
they like have more like it's really
exploded like the amount of food that
you can have and everything like always
comes with side dishes the traditional
ones that you always know like the bean
sprouts the kimchi the rice the fish the
the cucumbers of seaweed the onions like
all that good stuff and then the main
courses are just like soup based stuff
like barbecue stuff oh so good John I
think we need another man Charles go get
him babysit the wagon when you can sure
see you Arthur I think that dump next
time let the wolves eat all your brain
then you'll be a genius
Oh john marston do I have to go wait I
better not have to go all the way back
Abigail Abigail needs to speak with me
why does Abigail need to speak with me
what is okay don't know why Abigail
what's going on that's John marcin's
wife who I didn't recognize at first I'm
surprised I didn't but then again didn't
spend much time with Abigail in the last
game I think that speaks for itself
there's Alerus okay all right Abigail
what's up what's up Abigail Abbie we do
near Jack
Abby okay
can I ask you a favor
very funny would you do something with
Jack he seems kind of down all this up
people can't have been easy on the poor
kid why because I'm your preferred
nursemaid because he lacks you and well
you know his father's useless okay thank
you
pretty harsh very harsh ma'am nut bars
Dumbarton not utilize okay maybe he's a
little bit but I'm not I'm not that bad
I where's Jack Jack Jack come on yak-yak
hey Jack you want to go fishing
apparently I think this might be the
fishing tutorial I thought we were gonna
go no robbed a train or something but
apparently we're not hey Jack come here
you want to go fishing Jack come on
let's go fishing
hey Jack
you wanna come fishing with me fishing
sure it's about time that you started
earn your keep
okay good let's go get your polling how
you do have a fishing pole don't you
okay Rick
yeah whoa does a weird thing is like I
can see a world where this guy would be
a good dad okay all right let's go
that's a big bobber all right come on
come on dick oh my god this is awesome
God don't take it away from me they're
gonna rip it all away that's what
they're gonna do you know you know
[Music]
[Music]
this is our spot oh god this is so sweet
there's something off about Jack's voice
so okay you got it
you gotta you gotta you gotta I gotta I
gotta run fastest horse real fast
they're good boys boy I can't go no
faster you little [ __ ] I'm sorry I mean
Jack I'm literally trying to go as fast
as I possibly can kid listen I'm really
trying here all right Tokyo Drift stop
oh come on let me Tokyo Drift it in
[Music]
alright hop down making fun of my horse
or swoop oh you are strong and fast
don't listen to anything that Jack tells
you by the water dumbass good so stupid
yeah were what you think are you gonna
catch some land fish gotcha
can't wait to get started okay yeah sure
let's see what you watch oh yes smart
one as smart as your daddy it's by the
water you dumbass over here my god do I
have to spell it out for you okay what
do we got we got a fishing rod alright I
got my own here we need some bite okay
all right we got cheese good traditional
cheese bait corn bait
you some cheese Bell you're the better
now cast you the line
swing the rod back over your shoulder
and bringing it forward and smooth
motion use your wrist now your elbow
uh-huh
whoa wait for a fish to take the bait if
you feel the tip of your fishing rod
just twitching the only anchor yet
that just means once niblet if you feel
a hard tug that's a fish go for the bait
so hey Adam
you see really Wow I see two you ain't
so special I got eyes kid Oh see kid
[Music]
make sense to me make sense to me
get back in there don't go after my
cheese you know kid you you ain't you
weren't even caught nothing yet you're
stupid whatever you do you're gonna get
into trouble and I ain't gonna rescue
I'm gonna tell your papa when you've
gone over there
what do you mean that's a good-looking
spot Bram what you mean
try again what's wrong
Hey yeah like a pro like a pro like a
pro Amen now
I don't know if it's a big one it better
be a big one come on oh it looks big
who looks mighty big whoa there we go
that's a big one that's a nice not bad
I'll keep it I'll keep it up keep it oh
yes please brighten the roll sac all
right what do you think Jack Wow
[Music]
you can get food for days really if
you're lucky
put a tail then you just see it
wait try not to worry it's good for you
necklace mama
sure what a fine young man
and in such complex circumstances Arthur
isn't it Arthur Morgan Lulu yes Arthur
Morgan van der Linde most trusted
associate you read the vials typical
case orphan street kids seduced by that
maniac silver tongue and matures into a
degenerate murderer agent Milton agent
Ross Pinkerton Detective Agency seconded
to the United States government nice to
finally meet we know a lot about you do
you you're a wanted man mr. Morgan it's
$5,000 for your head alone $5,000 for me
gonna turn myself here we want vanderlin
no Dutch I haven't seen him for months
that's so because I heard guy fitting
his description robbed a train belonging
to Leviticus Cornwall up near granite
pass Oh ain't that a little
old-fashioned nowadays apparently not
listen this is my offer mr. Morgan bring
in Van der Lyn you have my word
you won't swing well I ain't gonna swing
anyways a gentle Milton you see I
haven't done anything wrong
aside from not playing the gangs to your
rules
spare me the philosophy lesson I've
already heard it from Mac calendar Mac
calendar he was pretty shot up by the
time I got to him so really it was more
of a mercy killing slow but merciful you
enjoy being a rich man's toy dear I
enjoy society flaws and all you people
venerate savagery and you will die
savagely all of you who were all gonna
die some of us sooner than others
good day mr. Morgan goodbye enjoy your
fishing Kid those are the same guys
those are the same guys those are the
same guys from the first game the same
sons of [ __ ] the same sons of [ __ ]
those are the same I don't like that man
I don't like them none none at all who
them's the same
those same sons of [ __ ] I know they
are and they cannot have a me and if
they're not the same than they look oh
so suspiciously much like
Big Sean I hope he's just found where he
is like I said don't worry about them
world is full of disagreeable man that's
why you got all of us cats so
fascinating to see how like history is
written from the victors like from this
perspective like because we all enjoy
society and yet you can kind of
empathize with him a murderous outlaw
it's like you're trying to ruin our way
of life just leave us alone
even though we're oh you know what's
wrong I better go speak with touch okay
hey you did real [ __ ] good job kid you
see how this guy might be a good dad
someday but Maggie I would I just met
some guys a fellow named detective
agency and they know about the Train and
they know well you followed back here no
they nowhere near here and they want you
Dutch they offered me my freedom in
exchange they did why didn't you take it
very funny well what do we do now
I say we do nothing just yet [ __ ] is
trying to scare us into doing something
stupid we have turned a corner we
survived them mountains we just need to
stay calm man now I'm grown used to the
beard I only want to change it anymore
mountain man okay so I guess now's the
time to do the John Marston mission
which is what we actually were out here
but that's a oh why is this waypoint
wait what I think the waypoint says
there might be a little brick broken
there but my god and then is crazy cuz I
really really wonder really really
wonder about things you know sometimes
cuz obviously society is a good thing
overall with flaws and whatnot but
generally speaking it's it's a good
thing oh no bottoms up Linda alright
yeah but it's like whoops what did I
just do whatever yeah it just comes down
to like these are satella it's like
exactly what the Pinkerton guy said he's
a douche he's just a slimy [ __ ]
the bastard but at the same time he's on
the quote-unquote right side of history
but it's like he said cuz these guys
live savage lives and their lives are
gonna end savagely and that is the truth
of it all but the story is still to be
told like the story is still be seen of
how these people live it's not good life
but it's a good life for them not good
for the people they're robbing it's not
good for the people they're killing
bad their destructive lives but for them
that's all they know okay fine by me you
don't need to do nothing about that yeah
missus this is a fascinating moral
dilemma like you can empathize with
someone but that doesn't mean that
they're in any way good oh is that the
horse that I stole oh sorry
how do ice I don't know how to just like
stop that is disgusting I want one that
let's see what we're dealing with here
ooh
uh-huh who Rodney that's so weird that
there's this rotten animals out here if
there's an animal that I killed like how
persistent is this world that's a
fascinating thing how persistent could
it be weird I don't know
also eventually I get to the point where
I start hunting birds because I know
that birds and bird feathers they're
good
what happened over there is the mindful
I think that might be my fault I
startled them Oh God Oh straining you
know the calming rain that'll make me
feel better I have no idea what the hell
just happened but uh okay I'll just
mosey on by to the rain I love the rain
I've said this before where what I'm not
doing I'm just okay we're up here now oh
okay all right
anyway I love the rain I do I really do
I've talked about it before but there's
something very calming about the rain
it's something that I miss when I'm out
in LA cuz it doesn't rain nearly enough
hardly at all and not that where I came
from was an exorbitant amount of rain
but there's always something very
calming about it it's soothing in a way
just to see the rain just sitting by a
window when it's raining and reading a
book I'm getting that primary you come
area oh you're a pretty one ancient I
marry you you can't run yeah
and Sartre
there we go all right please tell me
this is a good one
no yeah whatever
Oh - star whitetail buck okay can do all
right let's put you on the hump of the
horse or so you don't mind this isn't
too much cargo right yeah whatever
you're strong and what would we have
done without horses no probably not a
lot we'll be riding elephants everywhere
I wonder when I wonder what horses
actually came into play no idea there's
a lot of things in human history that I
just have no idea about okay alright is
this still leaking why don't I get rid
of the horses before yeah whatever John
John what are you doing John listen is
that's not John you all right there
hello can I help you
what do you care Englishman you've got
no time for me or you tried to find your
war foot then you're off cooking jobs
with other folks and your boy char
doesn't get it looking good so don't
want to get shot that's all yeah you're
a real [ __ ] funny [ __ ] after Morgan
huh real [ __ ] funny calm down you
better sleep with your eyes open here
you're gonna sleep with your chest open
if you ain't careful boy I love ya
Morgan I love ya come on take a shot
come on take your best shot please
come on which is great don't be playing
coy with me son it's unbecoming that
bloody train you and him has set up what
you're doing over here you're going to
need guns you're going to need men
oh so Marston told you it ain't a big
show I need calmness you come again
you're a dead man what's your problem
with me so many death threats I already
know you are threatened by me friend may
and will youthful vigor it intimidates
you does it it's a story as old as there
is the changing of the guard the fading
it Elise your oak stole mine okay now
were you pointing to future
you know its glory well good luck good
luck and shut up get some rest
man I wish I could do that just sleep
wherever whenever I needed close my eyes
way copulation what are you doing here
kid
I'm calming John on the job I said you
weren't coming yeah well just as I am
and it's his party boy so come on let's
go we had to make Jesus love it can't
wait to slit some bastard stroke you
sure about this
all right let's do this I'm ready I
wanted to rob a train on slip people's
throats I wanna sleep in the dirt I
wanna rub mud on my nipples I'm not
gonna battle cries
yeah Oh what yeah watch out everybody
get back other don't tell me what to do
[Music]
that requires a brain yeah folks you add
your feet off the whole toy plane sick
new look you're gonna play a breakfast
nimona you don't know what you're
talking about
stay close on this wouldn't want you
getting scratch for your swearing or
something
they're left here towards roads man
watch out watch out incoming incoming oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh oh
god oh god I tried to take one shortcut
guys I try to take one shortcut that's
not my fault
I tried to take one shortcut it all goes
to [ __ ] that's not my fault
that was the horses fault not guys I
don't know how to back up guy guys guys
guys I can't give me a second here oh my
god I don't know how to back up nobody
got that stuck I'm so [ __ ] stuck oh
my god no
are you doing oh my god I can't do it oh
god no oh oh
there I go alright we're tuning back in
for Sean to not shut up yeah I agree at
this point well you know it's better
than being an incessant jabber
okay stopping I don't know how to stop
[Music]
okay I think we're good do we light it
on fire we light it on fire right mr.
Smith mr. McGuire you there when she
slows food and you I'm gonna make sure
she slows I Stewart I watch you I like
it
get moving
hmm
ya ain't gonna be good okay yeah sure
let's do this like this why did we light
it on fire I thought we were gonna light
it on fire well that's scary I'm not
sure she's not gonna slow that's not
stopping time guys that's not enough
stopping time that for a train no way no
way no way in hell no way that's no good
at all there's no way I don't believe
that okay whatever the whole I'll
suspend my disbelief for a little bit
longer
all right I'm on the wrong side I think
I might be on the wrong side all right
oh no here we go
well well well howdy-do well well come
on now come on now come on now oh yes I
do
you ain't got nothing
well not playing games to bang
[Music]
whoo tough you tough bang tough how
tough you you tough huh let's don't ya
hey buddy gonna be hero anybody gonna be
tough yeah I'm here boy
how will you gonna get I'll get two
cents from your net there we go yeah
everyone think that they're smart you
are smart you smart you handsome - all
right whatever moving on all right who's
gonna be smart Manuel panting yes that's
is that I have worn duck foot Oh got him
well Shawn looks like I saved your skin
again oh whoops
yeah no no no don't look now duck what
would get your gun good no don't look at
the chest why you don't unders
you [ __ ] oh my god just shoot the man
shoot the man
[Music]
there you go all right now we look who
the hell whoa what what the hell well
what the hell happened what the hell the
law aright what Clark as I spent so much
time trying to loot that goddamn chest
I'm stupid alright let's go let's go
let's go
[Music]
not seeing much can't carry I can't
carry anymore because I have no idea
where to sell my stuff there's a few
more to torn off
okay let's deal with wobble no no no how
do I manually paint wait how do I do it
how do I do it how do I do it how do I
do it how do I do it how do i ban you
only paint in Deadeye
okay whatever whatever I don't know how
[Music]
there we go
okay
[Music]
point
I've completely lost the ability to pick
one shot at that off I can do that shot
his hat off too well I'm getting good at
that
not that I want that there we go that's
not so much the Hat you got it buddy you
got it friend
I got you John all right thank you
boy you're so nice okay we got to escape
the law I'm not gonna bother to Luanne
bye oh my dear still here
we ate no laws come from that direction
here let's go this way through the oil
let's go let's go boys let's go let's go
boys let's go we didn't lose him in the
woods some like that maybe I might be
able to lose him in the woods I'm not
sure
come on boy come on boy
there we go here we go here we go jump
no nevermind that was a gate yep
jump jump jump never go okay there we go
there we go okay did you get gone you
gon get gone get gone get gone there we
go there we go there we go there we go
and in the dense woods there boy there
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
okay that actually went surprisingly
well and I'm getting better at shootin
people even though I'd now I don't know
how the Dead Eye works horsey one still
need a real big tank enough for us to
get out of here was that setup law
turned up real fast I don't know I don't
think so I'm starting to get nervous
think they followed us from Blackwater
maybe they found me already near
horseshoe but I think this I was just
locals
I hope so I'm gonna head into Valentine
see if I can get something started there
who died dear either way we should all
go it alone right now you know the deal
don't follow me yeah of course not boss
alright good work everybody
whoa that's a big take that wasn't bad
at all there was a lot of money a lot of
moolah oh god now the only mission is
Micah and it's blinking at me oh I don't
wanna all right let me look up the
controls real quick because I just want
to make sure that I know exactly what
I'm doing
reload is circle ah
ah tag target is r1 okay all right now
I've got it okay now I've got it okay
now I got it all right I gotta stop into
Valentine I drop off this horse oh my
god we are way way way out we are way
out
stagecoach we return to a location that
you have previously visited for a feat
that that sounds good but before I do
that I'm going to go here let's do a
little bit of this why have I not been
unlocking that I didn't know about that
that that that's nice that's real nice
well I don't do that that sounds real
good I like that I like that but first
I'm gonna go to work I gotta go what oh
wait I'm over here but let me go get
this first Billy midnight let me go to
Billy hi Billy
I build a midnight Billy Billy yeah hell
are you here you want to buy a deer up a
bounty let's just go ahead and do that
I'm the bad person all right
before hurry come through here name of
midnight Billy oh that old soak yeah he
spends days on board these trains but
he's going nowhere but the gutter
I imagine you find him riding the next
one through here either that or the next
one time both look in the bar car okay
all right easy enough Billy Billy Billy
so you know he'll be live Billy Billy
Billy Billy Billy Billy mr. midnight
listen this won't take a moment
I just want to talk with you about your
old days okay all right well that's all
bizarre huh put the chair back Nessa
cuz I got play wave-wave did the piano
player pick up music specifically
designed for this chase did he start
just booting hard oh god I hope so
right okay
can I get a picture of this
[Music]
foolish
today
okay okay I know what whoa what the hell
happened
we've what the [ __ ]
got him
hey wait no no no no no no no no what no
was something that was gonna kill me
ere we go and
no no no no no no what the [ __ ]
how'd that kill him shot him in his hand
oh whatever I guess there's no way all
right here we go
wait no they're gonna get back up a bit
what is sad
now I'm now getting his face [ __ ] god
[ __ ] criminy Christmas piece of
poopie [ __ ] mangling piece of crap it's
not my fault guys what okay there's no
way to not shoot him because that was
like a dead shot of the gun and if that
didn't work then there's no way
anything's gonna work Tom's are gonna
take my picture I'm gonna take your
picture and then that's gonna be the end
of it you understand me I'm just gonna
take this grim picture and
shabu ski okay got it
I'm happy about that anyway horsey oh my
horsey how you doing
don't worry I'm fine it's all good I'm
fine oh good I don't have to do Micah's
stupid mission oh not okay okay so we're
just gotta get back to town I'm gonna
donate this carcass in camp because I
got no other place for it so I might as
well just give it over there hello cow
bull excuse me honk whoo sorry whoa that
was a close one
somebody dying over there
nah my problem not my issue all right so
I got three pelts I got some bird
feathers I got a good stuff I don't care
what you have to get a drink about this
isn't about you this isn't your story so
I gotta go find the butcher and not run
into a rock on the way there oh my gosh
and then I gotta sell this [ __ ] I'm
gonna go in the general store and I'm
really gonna dump like a lot of stuff
all over the place
excuse me beep beep by the horse get out
of my way you slow down you stupid okay
so also I'm getting a lot better at a
number one just kidding
okay skipping is also something I'm good
at apparently or I'll just not do
anything about what there can I have
these no can I can I have all right
whatever horse you stay there I'm gonna
sell whatever I can you know
yeah yeah yeah whatever hang on let me
sell all this [ __ ] oh I can't sell it
straight off my horse that's fine okay
good that's a good bit of money I didn't
even pay attention to how much money was
because I was stupid and I didn't want
to know 60 cents mansions forgive me
forgive me for what I'm about to do to
this man here I'm gonna give you the
bargain of a lifetime here we go sell my
sellers [ __ ] I don't even man but it's
good sure this OBE this solemn I want it
you might want it sir
all right that all I can sell is that
all I could legitimately sell cuz if it
is goddamn you sir I bought this [ __ ]
from you
I bought this someone might want it I
need to get my me my 30 man you say okay
I don't know the purpose of a bank would
I have any business in a bank besides
robbing it how's it going I'm just well
hello sir anyway I guess I'm not gonna
talk to you because I'm not in after you
here well alright mister I'm reformed
I'm all better now
yeah okay whatever I'm gonna find
wherever John Marston is John John John
John John where are you John John John
okay
and before we get that that's all the
time I got for this episode here thank
you everybody so much for watching hope
you're enjoying this so far I know I am
and now that
getting a better grasp but this game
only a few hours into it I'm having a
much better time with it so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye